i have no interest in in dropping back
50 times if we don't need to i'd like to
win the way we did last week if that's
the way it can happen
so
i'll play whatever game is called
whatever game we need and all that
really matters is that we find a way at
the end to win and i'm not going to
nitpick or look at any of the
steps along the way to get there let's
just win
kirk cousins vikings quarterback
sporting the early season playoff beard
i don't know how i feel about a beard on
kirk cousins and i say that as someone
who could never pull off a beard if you
can't pull off a beard don't try that's
my free male grooming advice today but
far more importantly it's time to play a
little what's more likely kirk cousins
is the first topic today and this one
this one i'm intrigued by yeah i've gone
back and forth on this one what's more
likely saquon barkley has another game
with 11 carries or
kirk cousins has another game with only
10 pass attempts what's more likely
i think this is a tough one i think i
would go though with saquon barkley has
another game of 11 carries where like
let's state this that should never
happen okay he should never have 11
carries but i do think it's more likely
than you know kirk cousins having 10
past attempts in a game and why do i say
that because i think the way the vikings
won is a very rare way with a you know
block punt all the interceptions down in
the you know in the red zone that led to
a short field those things where i could
see the giants getting in some games
where yeah things get out of hand and
then they can't give them the ball in
the run game and they have to throw to
come back and uh play that style of
football on offense yeah you know i
agree with you completely i mean i could
see the vikings continuing their
commitment to the running game all year
long because it worked with alvin cook
and alexander madison the rookie from
boise state but
but to get to only 10 throws you do have
to have multiple short fields which is
what they had you you get up big and
then you don't why why especially week
one right why show any of your passing
game if you don't have to 28 nothing for
crying out loud so i think it's far less
likely that we'll see the vikings have
cousins only throw 10 passes again far
more likely that either due to
incompetence or circumstance saquon
barkley will only have 11 carries i i
think we're on the same page on that one
all right who is more likely to sustain
his performance lamar jackson or kyle
murray well
this is an easy one i'm going with kyla
murray because lamar jackson had like a
career day i mean that could very easily
be like the best day in the history of
his career at that point or any
quarterback would take that day and say
dan that was one of the better days of
my career so i do go with kyla murray
here just because again kyler murray
didn't like blow the doors off to oh my
gosh this is the most unbelievable stuff
we've ever seen no it was very you know
underwhelming for a long long time but
then late in the fourth quarter he made
just two or three throws and then
another amazing throw in overtime that
kind of changed the game in general and
i could see that being a style of play
by arizona all year long
but you're right i mean this is one of
those where you really got to pay
attention to the question in the
circumstance because lamar jackson
set a bar so much higher than anyone
last week it's going to be almost
impossible to continue it and for kyla
murray first three quarters not good
fourth quarter they figured it out
i i think i i hope that it's a good game
on sunday i mean i i think we look at it
and say man the ravens should win this
one at home arizona's coming all the way
across the country and they were down
24-6 and the ravens have a better
defense yadda yadda but this you know
even though they're going to see each
other once every four years savor it
when they do kyla murray versus lamar
jackson i agree with you it's more
likely murray sustains his performance
because it wasn't nearly as spectacular
as lamar jackson's all right sammy
watkins and desean jackson each had
multiple touchdown catches over 40 yards
last week who's more likely to go 40
plus yards again this week sammy watkins
of the chiefs or deshawn jackson of the
eagles gosh this now this really is this
is like because these two guys are both
like focal points for their offense as
far as down the field shots i don't feel
comfortable with any answer here i'm
gonna go with sammy watkins i guess
only because of this because of patrick
mahomes and the kansas city chiefs
offense which is always looking for a
handful of deep shots every game and not
just deep shots within like the normal
flow of the game these are deep shots
where andy reid has been the mad
scientist all week and he found a few
plays that he knows are going to screw
over this defense at this time of the
game i don't feel great about that one
because i know wentz is a good deep ball
thrower and we know desean jackson is
awesome but i'm gonna go with sammy
watkins just because of that chief's
offense
yeah but i'm gonna go with desean
jackson because of that that history of
performance we've seen from him and all
the times he's gone over 50 yards in his
career and without tyree kill on the
field sammy watkins now becomes the guy
that the raiders defense is game
planning to stop desean jackson still
has al shawn jeffrey and i don't even
know that he needs he can he is the guy
sammy watkins has never really been the
guy on a sustained basis no he steps
into that role now and and i think that
you're going to see a concerted effort
to take him away and force patrick
mahomes to go elsewhere so that's no
doubt shawn jackson you're right no
those are all good points this is a
tough one i mean i i mean your points
are spot on i just i'm just hoping andy
reid's got something for those you know
those fused plays but we'll see we'll
see what was more likely next week when
we do
what is more likely
we never go back and i know how the last
ones turned out so who knows we could
say whatever we want we're never wrong
because we never we never grade the test
next one freddie kitchens rallies the
browns for a great performance on monday
night football or the browns lose again
and cleveland's misery continues what's
more likely
i'm gonna go with freddie kitchen's
rallies to browns for a great
performance i am i i don't know why i
still got faith in freddie kitchens and
baker mayfield the defense played good
the other day in that titans game we
know it was baker mayfield just going
through a stretch of really the worst
stretch we've seen him have in his
career i don't think he'll replicate
that especially don't expect that and
here's the other thing i'll say you know
freddy kitchens is gonna have a good
feel for greg williams defense more than
vice versa right because greg williams
in training camp last year he went
against hugh jackson's offense right and
freddie he never really had a go against
freddy's offense so freddie i think
we'll have greater knowledge of greg
williams and i do worry about the
corners for the new york jets it is not
a great group and i'm not so sure they
match up that well with uh these wide
receivers in cleveland
i
you know i i am by no means a star wars
geek but i am thinking of the scene from
the original star wars movie which would
be episode four when they're in the
trash compactor and the walls just begin
to cry
i feel like for the browns the walls are
closing in and they're closing in and
the pressure is mounting and here's
monday night football and even though
it's the jets you can feel that and it's
palpable and they've got the rams coming
up and they've got big games after that
and you just i don't know that freddie
kitchens is able to find the off switch
this is a guy who a year ago was a
running backs coach for crying out loud
i'm not saying he can't
but i'm just saying it's not going to be
easy and the last thing we saw from this
team was a loss by 30. so so what are
you saying is what what are you saying
is what i want to know because that was
a nice high-wire dance act there to say
a lot of nice and crap at the same time
what is more likely mike florio
well is it possible they don't have a
great performance but they still win
there's two choices ugly great
performance on monday night football are
the browns lose again and the misery
continues there's two choices you have
to pick one of them what's more likely
i am aware of the rules i'll say between
those two choices browns lose again
because i think the most likely scenario
is the browns win in ugly fashion and
just get out of there before they get
their butts kicked at home by the rams
six days later all right last one
quarterback more likely to keep his team
in playoff conversation
joe flacco or gardner minshew the second
gesundheit
gosh
i don't well
honestly
i feel better about gardner minshew
right now okay
because again i haven't watched that
that broncos raiders film
but just the way the broncos offense
looked in general you know i still got
questions about that o line
and i know mike munchex there and he'll
get some of that straightened out but i
i do think there's issues there there
was a lot of plays where joe flacco was
holding the ball it didn't look like
anybody was open when you saw replays on
tv things like that
and i just look at guard gardner minshew
and things look good i mean he played
good it was 23-13 they were driving in
field goal position and leonard
fournette fumbled i'm going with him too
just because of the team around him i
still think this defense is better than
the one in denver i think their run game
is better than in denver and honestly
think he has better weapons in the past
game around him than joe flacco i'm
going with the the jags and minsha
minshew minshee's got minshew uh but
then she's got a little bit of a cannon
there as he's firing that ball out and
he really was a a machine at washington
state fifth in the heisman voting also
consider the competition broncos have
already lost to the raiders they got to
deal with the chargers twice and the
chiefs twice the jaguars in that afc
south which feels diminished due to
injuries and just ineffectiveness i i
think that uh i got a little more faith
in in gardner-minshew i'm not ready to
abandon my afc south pick okay yes i
also recognize that nick foles will be
back at some point right but uh i don't
know i don't know maybe they'll apply
100 rule to nick falls once he's healthy
if gardner minshew is getting it done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports